[Music]
from the love child of joe rogan and
michael bay
comes a zack snyder film with no one at
the studio telling him how to write a
script
easy peasy japanese how to direct a
performance
and i'll probably die or how to focus
the camera
focus focus please focus
focus now and focus
focus focus
focus army of the dead
zombies have taken over las vegas thanks
to roadhead gone wrong
and now the whole city looks like a
spirit halloween the paintball field
with the government from idiocracy all
set to drop a nuke
dropping the nuke on the fourth would be
quote really cool
and actually kind of patriotic if you
think about it there's just a few days
left for a billionaire to hire some
mercs to rob his own casino
but don't worry that dumb plan is just
cover for the military's even dumber
plan
power to control your own zombie army
which is his cover for one woman's even
dumber plan to avoid raising some kids
in case anything happens to me in the
next few days just make sure the kids
make it out to burst okay
i'm coming with you which is just cover
for one company's even dumber plan to
launch an entire shared universe
off one average zombie movie hey
remember when we had way too much zombie
stuff
like five years ago cool cool cool
if you want to pull off a great heist
you're gonna need the perfect crew
gear up with one damaged badass one
damaged badass
one damaged badass one damaged badass
a couple of fun-loving badasses and the
world's most obvious traitor
i don't trust you i don't trust that guy
i don't trust any of these people but
especially you
but no crew is truly complete without a
show stealing comic relief
and no one knocks those roles out of the
park like cristig
nataro because when you get a pro like
tig
nataro you just sit back and let tig
nataro
do what tig nataro does best
appeal to a younger audience experience
a film about broke veterans stealing
money during a zombie
apocalypse that's somehow not a
commentary on anything
we're not in america anymore haven't you
heard which
technically makes it an even freer
country right
whatever where the only thing is the
zero the team gives about each other
don't go
no more team i brought a guy in one slow
side of them had to leave him
what are we doing just go let's go
oh reboir come on leave her she's done
don't screw me just go so that's a
pretty common theme for you
leaving people behind but there's no
time for social satire
when there's so many awesome ideas to
introduce and never follow up on
like robot zombies what's their deal who
knows
rain zombies you should see what happens
when it rains for a few hours they'll
come back to life
we should see that but we don't zombie
sex
how's that possible tbd and the awesome
zombie killing saw that keeps getting
teased you ready to play
don't even touch my soul again okay oh
man
here it comes it's zombie saw in time
wait what they only use it to make a
door it's not her saving the good stuff
for the prequel the sequel
the anime prequel or the snyder cut so
settle in for some classic snyder
that may not be his best zombie flick
but it's got a great opening credit
sequence
then a bunch of overlong nonsense that's
not as fun as it should be
especially when you put a better idea
for a movie in the movie
there's another team of grave robbers it
could be us in another timeline
and we're caught in some infinite
loop of fighting and dying i would much
rather watch that story
any idea what the hell we're hauling
amelia earhart
but alive or that one open a new food
truck
sneaking artisan grilled cheese
sandwiches or that one
starring dave bautista looking like he's
holding in a sneeze
clockwise orange chris deleted
psalms of anarchy tommy wiseau
you saw nothing i guess lula had a
scheduling conflict
zom influencer eight simple rules for
eviscerating my teenage daughter
get over here and run my casino for me
tricky martin
lily vegas multi-pass and
i'm dead
world war
you know you think a guy on his way to
steal 200 million dollars in cash would
have a better plan for carrying it all
up to the roof i mean i know he's shaped
like an upside down triangle and all but
that's 4
400 pounds dude i need you to get all
the way
off my back about how the movies are
being written
finger licking good he's about to get
his soul sucked
you can tune a piano but you can't tuna
fish
see you at the muvies